[Music]
it's uh it's great to see you my friend
I don't see you often enough and it's
its gift and an honor to be able to
reprise a conversation that we started I
think it was six years ago yes sitting
in the cabin of a cruise ship in the
Bermuda Triangle in the early days of
the show hmm
we've come a long way since then but
your message has remained consistent
you've done so many amazing things over
the course of your career you really are
a gift to to health and humanity so
first of all I just want to say that
publicly thank you thank you and I'm
really interested in in hearing more
about this next chapter that you've been
on going around in medical schools and
and and lecturing to medical students
about nutrition which seems to be you
know a much-needed thing and and quite
overdue so how did this whole thing come
about and which thank you so much for
the invitation it's great to see your
smiling face and cross the table here
and commend you for all your wonderful
work and you've been an inspiration
steadily for be it every time I get
whether you're good at reuse I think I'm
gonna get back on that show again yo
here we are we are great so such an
important question that you asked modern
medicine and I've been a physician now
for teach seven years and I entered
medicine in late 60s early 70s and seen
lots of wonderful changes and it's
become powerful on a level that none of
us have been able to conceive of but
there's been there's glaring grotesque
absence this black hole when it comes to
true causes of disease the true powerful
healing techniques and of course we're
talking about what our patients are
reading and Western medicine has evolved
or devolve to the point where we
practice medicine we take histories we
order all these tests to physical exams
and never once asked the
what do you read me through yesterday's
eating day and and if such a huge
oversight because that's by and large
the reason why the patient is sitting in
front of us overweight and hypertensive
and diabetic and clogged up and inflamed
because of what they're running through
their bloodstream every few hours and
yeah we just blow right past as far from
the medical point of view it doesn't
even enter the equation of what's
happening and that leads to such not
only inefficiency but everything from
wrong diagnosis to wrong treatment to
real patients dying on real operating
tables from operations they don't need
so at this point my medical career I've
had to say seeing another elderly person
with constipation is not the best use of
my energy you should do something about
that so I so the campaign be are moving
medicine forward initiative this it came
from there and you you're doing this
with plant pure or like foundation right
it's like a 501 C 3 yes I'm very
appreciative to the folks at planter
communities they we entered into an
agreement where if people want to
support our work getting me in front of
medical school audiences if they give a
donation to planetary communities they
it finds its way to our own nonprofit
account here so they've kind of extended
their umbrella over us a bit and it
certainly has made a big difference as
far as that you some getting some
support so how many medical schools have
you lectured so far we've been to just
about twenty and we've got another for a
lined up here I'm going to be going to
University of Texas in Houston Dallas
San Antonio then the University of
Arkansas then we got a swing for the
Northeast going to be going to Rutgers
University of Massachusetts
we were just up at University of
Washington Seattle University of Florida
in Gainesville
now all medical audiences are the folks
are my friend and say at this point I
want to reach as many first-year
students as I can before pharmaco
sclerosis sets into their
I like that I'd never heard that before
like that and even the only treatments
drugs yeah no doctors there's a there's
a better more elegant way to approach
the condition here so so give me a
synopsis or like a truncated version of
what it is that you speak about when you
get in front of these students well as I
step up to the microphone I tell them
listen I'm gonna give you them the
lecture I wish somebody had given me 50
years ago 50 freakin years has been
since I was a first year medical student
1968 but if somebody had told me now
what I tell us to listen you're gonna be
learning from men--they about these
weird and wonderful diseases from
smallpox to leprosy but the reality is
when you open the door of your waiting
room of your clinic or the emergency
department or surgical outpatient you're
not going to be seeing patients we're
not gonna sleep I thank God it's gonna
be obesity and diabetes and clogged
arteries and inflammatory diseases from
what your patients are eating and unless
you get real with that then you're gonna
miss the diagnosis about what's really
staring you in the face and your
treatments can be inappropriate it's
gonna be band-aid medicine if the
patient's making themselves sick with or
what they're reading every few hours and
you're they're just there to raise their
statin dosage or raise their metformin
dosage or its bankrupt medicine you're
not helping that patient you're
perpetuating their problems right so in
terms of unpacking the nutrition side of
this I mean you're coming from a whole
food plant-based perspective I'm
interested in how that's received from
the medical school community I mean
obviously you know even in the period
since we first did this podcast the
movement has grown tremendously it's
incredible what's happening now even
versus then but as somebody who's been
in this I mean you graduate med school
in like 72 right and then went vegan I
think about 10 years later so you've
been doing this for a long time you've
been treating patients forever
I'm sure there were there were decades
in there where you were this crazy
maverick and you know fighting the
system and you know perhaps on some
level you're still doing that although I
would imagine the reception is a little
bit more welcoming correct
I'm very perceptive and you're
the first part of my lecture and I want
to talk science these young students and
so I've got it's it's a two-pronged
attack your one is to convince them that
food has anything to do with these
diseases again geez the etiology unknown
yeah a autoimmunity we don't know why
the body attacks itself but the smart
guys at NIH are working 24/7 and when
they come up with the answer they'll
design a maze Ocilla and give it to us
to restore our patients or perfect
health well it's not going to happen and
so I showed them slide two what happens
to their blood after they eat rice and
beans and greens and what happens to
their blood after they eat a
cheeseburger and a milkshake yeah and I
show them all the fat in the blood and
all the inflammatory proteins all the
things that that percolate through the
system hour after hour not only that but
month after month year after year they
tell them were shocked when when the
inflammation appears in the body we were
puzzled when the arteries start platting
up with evel's chlorosis we can't figure
out why the guy's joints erupted it with
autoimmune arthritis and certainly that
colon cancer that that popped out of the
colon GI was just bad luck bad genes
well nonsense it's tough for houd it's
the food it's what they're eating these
diseases are not suppose to happen now
spontaneously it's it's the fuel we're
putting through through the system it's
we've been putting diesel fuel through a
gasoline burning engine and we get all
these all this dysfunction so my first
task is just to make the connection
between food and and disease and health
if you do it right and then we move
delicately into the issue of
animal-based foods versus plant-based
foods and how fundamentally the diet
changes we you people put a piece of
animal flesh into the intestinal tract
two or three times a day you're gonna
change everything from the flora from
the battery that live in the gut now to
the chemistry of the blood to these what
you're smearing on the colon wall to the
the leakiness that you of the intestinal
wall as you create that lease autoimmune
disease
changes everything and and it's you know
politically dicey a lot of folks are and
the students and their professors are
into paleo diets etc but I said listen
we're basically plant eating creatures
we our simian ancestors have been on
this planet for 20 million years eating
leaves and fruits our bonobo and gorilla
cousins are up in the trees today eating
leaves and for plant eating creatures
and as long as we eat a plant
predominant diet you don't have to be a
hundred percent vegan but if the
majority of what goes down your gullet
is whole plant foods leaves and greens
and fruits and vegetables your body turn
a thrive on that and we talk about
disease reversal in fact I put that
concept up on those on the slide disease
reversal I was a physician 45 years
before anybody even put those two words
in the same sentence for me that these
are reversible diseases these Sderot the
diabetes and high blood pressure and the
the inflammatory arthritis these
diseases go away with a healthy diet and
so towards the end I put up a fairly
controversial set of slides where I show
them the list of the classic diseases
diabetes hypertension etc and I with
another click of the slide the words
reversible comes ago these are all
reversible diseases and then the most
controversial slide I put up by clickin
as a want to heal these patients or
don't you I mean really why'd you go
into medicine want to heal these people
then get real about what they're eating
because that's why they're sitting in
front of you we've been we've been
treating the patient's diet like in the
Harry Potter movies of all the bark you
know the name they must not be spoken
don't ask what the patient's eating
we're Americans we can eat whatever we
want yeah but your arteries got
something to say about them and prostate
glands yes I'm say but your your
intestinal tract of something say buddy
your diverged got something to say about
it because he's gonna or she's gonna be
dealing with the consequences of that
and so let's get real about what the
patient's eating because it's got such a
powerful factor so so I've got these
powerful
concepts to wheel in during the course
my slide presentation but it's a bit
easier as you implied because in our
2020 and in every first second third
year medical school class now there's
twenty or thirty students they've seen
movies like forks over knives they've
seen what the hell they've seen Cal
spirit the lights on they they get that
there's something to this nutrition
thing they caught you and probably the
most Mima Bowl quotable in all of us it
was at what the health or cowspiracy
what it what dairy is house no is baby
calf growth flu that is traveled far and
wide across and so in that way it's a
little easier either there was often
allies in the audience among the
students but there's always a bunch of
professors in the back of the room with
their arms folded and or tongues going
cluck-cluck but they're alive they'll
either get on board or they'll be pushed
aside that this wave is breaking and
there's no stopping it food is is really
where it's at as far as healing goes in
modern medicine yes right so for that
essentially the the student body these
younger people are much more receptive
to it than the institution absolutely
the institution you know is the one that
green lights you to come and speak in
the first place so there has to be some
Amin ability to what you have to share
yes point that the administration of
these medicals they don't want to hear
from dr. Klapper they the message is
disruptive their rates their models and
so we go right to the students we hear
they're the ones they're the ones they
invite me and they arrange they reserve
the lecture hall they arrange for the
Indian restaurant to bring over the
samosas and for a lunchtime rounds and
so we dealing right with the students
and and we ask them to form a nutrition
interest group so after I leaves with
it's not a one time drive-by lecture
they
a nutrition interest group and once a
month I'll Skype in we'll talk about
nutrition based cases what will keep the
light on as far as their awareness how
important nutrition is in their patients
yeah that's crucial I mean that was my
next question it's great for you to pop
in for a couple hours but what is the
legacy of that let you know and unless
they create a curriculum around it or
there's some kind of follow-up to you
know create some momentum around this
then you know how impactful can it
possibly be I mean how far away are we
from from really kind of canonizing
nutrition studies in medical schools so
that we can create a new generation of
people who are well versed and what is
so important in terms of treating
patients all right you you put your
finger right on it of course and I gave
a lecture up and down in Seattle and
professor surgery and I came down
afterwards and said nice lecture doc
very import good stuff but I'll tell you
until the national board of medical
examiners that starts asking questions
on the national board about nutrition
we're not going to be teaching this
stuff it's enough for us to get in
surgery and biochemistry and physiology
we're and the nutrition is just not on
the radar screen and when he said that I
think you know he's right and so from
that has come a real initiative largely
spearheaded by the American College of
lifestyle medicine to get questions
about nutrition on the national board
exams and so we went to the national
board of medical examiners and they we
told them that and they say okay very
grudgingly but we don't know anything
about it about nutrition and lifestyle
medicine you guys make up the questions
and and we'll we'll put a few of them on
the exam so they put the ball back in
the court of Mara College of lifestyle
medicine where I am a member and so we
are now engaged in a process of creating
a pool of a thousand questions to give
to the national board of medical
examiners and to have them take a sample
of them to put on the exam so then we
can start going to the medical schools
and say this is going to be honored
now oh it's real now you have to retouch
it oh yeah
sad because they don't realize the jewel
listen from this is the key to the
healing yeah again and they're gonna be
grudgingly give it a little bit of
energy on the test and I'm afraid
knowing the reality of it there's gonna
be a question about olive oil and
another one about getting enough sleep
and you know they'll give a token
recognition but as far as really getting
into plant-based nutrition I'm gonna
have to keep working at the coalface for
a while to get that real right over the
course of your many decade career I'm
sure you've seen diet trends and fads
come and go and you know it's
interesting to see what sticks and what
doesn't and what passes I'm sure you've
seen it all and right now we're in a
moment where we are seeing you know the
explosion of interest in plant-based
diets and the science that backs it up
in lockstep with that though there's
also a very you know strident growing
movement around low-carb eating and keto
diet and so I'm sure these questions
come up all the time especially with
these students and just in general so
how do you kind of think about that and
how do you communicate around those
other protocols and what is your
perspective on them oh my daugther
showed it so you got time time okay well
this is like you know listen there's a
lot of plant-based people that listen to
the show but there's people that are on
different kinds of diets absolutely and
I think the reason I'm asking you this
question is you know for even a very
well-educated motivated listener or just
consumer in general they go online or
they you know read whatever's happening
and they see the stuff about plant-based
but they also see the stuff about keto
and low-carb and it's confusing even if
you're you know going to PubMed and and
reading abstracts which almost no one
does it's still confusing right there's
science to support different
perspectives and it's all very
disorienting and so I'm always trying to
drive people towards you know what is
common-sense here you know what are the
facts really
said what does the science really say
and what are some principles that we can
hang our hat on that can guide us in a
trajectory that's doable in the context
of our busy lives very important of
course so put on our miner's cap here
and drill down there enough and it
starts with a recognition on everyone's
part how toxic the standard Western diet
has become and if you're especially a
even dabbling in fast foods at all every
piece of meat you eat is going to be
come with with white bread and sugary
ketchup and hydrogenated oils and and
the toxic load that comes with whether
it's the peaches or the burgers or the
buffalo wings etc and all the diets who
are serious about getting people
healthier whether it's paleo or keto or
plant-based whatever now all of us we
all we strip away that that outer whole
of toxic you know we can all agree that
we all agree the standard American diet
the fast-food diet is bad in dude and
once you do that that that step alone is
a quantum leap is a huge improvement and
you reduce a huge load of refined sugars
and and fats and foods that are grossly
obese oh genic and as a result people as
panel especially the the paleo folks
strip out the dairy products as well and
as well as the oils and will you take
out the dairy the oils and and junk
flour products people are going to lose
weight and the very act of losing weight
does good things in most people's bodies
and their lipid profiles get better
their diabetes gets better they feel
better their energy level goes up and so
you see this improve this initial
improvement in health in most all of
these dietary styles and it's enough to
provide very powerful reinforcement yeah
I went paleo boy I lost weight felt good
man it's the diet for me
and I hear that word with the Quito
folks as well but as a physician and as
a person who respects the biology of
this body that we have I mean no gorilla
packs its intestines full of meat
through three times a day like we do and
having been in the medical game for so
long I have to say wait a minute
grant did you see this initial
improvement but I urged well do not be
seduced by this improvement that you're
seeing now what the reality is you
packed that colon full of meat to three
times a day a day now and you send the
surge of cholesterol and saturated fat
and oxidized meat proteins through those
tissues day after day after day as the
months go by as the years go by this is
a recipe for colon cancer this is a
recipe for artery disease as a recipe
for strokes recipe for dementia recipe
for autoimmune disease from leaky gut
and the problem and and I put this my
slideshow so medicines become very
segmented medical cures become very
fractionated very segmented and the odds
of you seeing the same doctor when you
go back to the clinic or small doctors
move away patients move away and the
point is people know the specially these
young Doc's make these recommend all you
ought to eat paleo you're already keto
and then you never see them again and I
asked those young dot you make these
recommendations you got to be around in
ten years when this guy passes his first
bloody stools and that colon cancer that
your diet spawned you read me around to
see it you'll be around 12 years this
lady's joints light up from the
autoimmune arthritis that your diet is
leaky gut gave her you won't be around
to see it you think you've done
something good for her but you're gonna
be around in 15 years when when this guy
has a stroke from that carotid plaque
that your diet stirred up in his
arteries or you won't be around to see
that and that's my concern as a seasoned
physicians have been in this game a
while now what are you really brewing up
in these patients colons what are you
really brewing up in their arteries what
are you really brewing up in their
joints what are you brewing up in their
immune systems and their prostate glands
and their colon and their breast tissue
yeah and and the folks were making these
initial recommendations don't I say do
you really know what you're doing doctor
you know the Fred do no harm' applies to
dietary advice as well and you can
really hurt somebody with the wrong diet
and I think a lot of wrong advice is
being given yeah we're plant eating
creatures we need to be true to that can
you have a little piece of flesh once or
twice a week yeah probably get away with
it but but we're not Homo carnivorous
we're not flesh-eating Apes and we're
meant to run on whole plant foods and
when we do that the body gets lean and
healthy and the arteries open up
inflammation subsides and right the body
has to find a word on that so you are 71
right now what only 272 I can only
aspire to be as vibrant and as healthy
and as handsome as you 72 so for me it's
like the proof is in the pudding I mean
you obviously you know I've been living
this lifestyle for a very long time and
you're an incredible living example of
the benefits of it I mean you're not you
know medications right I mean you know
it's to me it's like there you go right
so I look at you I hear what you're
saying
and then I log on to Twitter and I see
the debates and the kind of tribalism
and the silos and you know unhealth talk
about disease you know there's a disease
of communication happening right now and
it's become really kind of I mean
acrimonious is real gentle a word of
people infighting and you see this even
within the vegan community there was a
flare-up you know this week that we
don't need to get into but but you know
I I think often and I don't really
participate in that but I observe it you
know sort of take a forensic you know
look at what's happening and it's deeply
concerning to me because the people that
are consuming that are just like I said
earlier the average consumer and I think
if foments more confusion than clarity
and I'm interested in your thoughts on
how we can you know create a healthier
dialogue and
flow of information about these
important ideas because truly as you
mentioned earlier people's lives really
are hanging in the balance here
absolutely and you you touched on the
major points that they often get lost
here the especially the folks in the
plant-based community we're a small
community yeah we've got a big idea that
we're trying to to widely promulgate and
we and all this petty infighting
certainly doesn't help the public looks
deaf these guys don't have their act
together it certainly doesn't help the
larger mission so one thing to do is for
everybody take a step back and say what
are we trying to accomplish here we're
trying to get them plant-based eating
widely-accepted
and the least we can do now is talk
civilly to each other and realize that
we all are in the same boat rowing in
the same direction here and in we're all
learning we're all on the same journey
together here and to have respect for
each other's journeys and if something
goes by that you have scientific
disagreement with it then express it as
civilly professionally and and back up
your reasoning why and and doesn't have
to be done in public you can write
someone a private emails that you know I
saw something you published and you
might want to consider point a B and C
about that and you want to talk about
this there's a way to communicate
civilly and professionally and and
that's there's been one of the
casualties here and we need you
everybody take a step back and and and
because we're all friends we all like
each other it's time to treat each other
as such yeah as well as professionals
yeah and get our communications on a
level that then are not too injurious
it's super important what's your take on
this sort of explosion of the carnivore
diet that suddenly came out of nowhere
and is capturing people's fascination
yeah like my friend John McDougall says
people loved if you're good news about
bad habits you know they like that taste
of steak in their mouth so if a little
is good let's do more is better but it
got even just more like a hundred
percent yeah you know
we're not carnivorous Apes and this is a
recipe for colon cancer and and strokes
and autoimmune disease and they're going
to learn the hard way I've already seen
this the studies showing up in the
journals that the folks who eat all the
meat would have lots of this TMAO
molecule in their bloodstream from the
from the carnitine metabolism that the
that these microbes want this is not a
karma free diet to say the least and
that pendulum is going to swing back
hard and then you're going to see the
the studies start showing out carnivore
diet associated with colon cancer
carnivore dad is associated with
Alzheimer's carnivore died associated
with yeah and my left eyebrow won't go
up this much when I read them yeah I
know
yeah that's kind of expected those
headlines and that's what they're gonna
see in the pantheon of harm how do you
you know differentiate or distinguish
between meat or chicken and beef and
pork versus oils versus dairy like how
do you come home ah hey there's there's
a choice and again less of toxicologists
say the dose makes the poison and a
little a teaspoon of oil is probably not
gonna hurt anybody and a and the small
little bite of cheese probably not don't
anybody hello piece of meat anyone
it's the its building your diet around
these are staples is where the problem
comes in and they each have their
adverse effects unique to them and the
now the very act of cooking meat
oxidizes cholesterol which is
atherogenic it creates carcinogens it
does all these things that the oils
don't and the and the dairy doesn't but
the oils injure the artery walls and
they Lin they now increase the risk of
atherosclerosis formation the dairy
products are loaded with everything from
from estrogens to leukemia viruses you
know and you want to remember to rather
be shot or hung yeah so
they're all pretty evil if in a survival
situation you know and probably the the
meat would you know small amounts would
be less dangerous but again we're
talking about some tiny bit just amounts
not being a mission your diet around it
right so you you grew up on a dairy farm
I did there is I think maybe we talked
about this last time but there seems to
be a high percentage of plant-based
doctors that grew up on dairy farms in
general I don't know what that's about
but maybe it's just seeing up I mean I'm
sure that you know the dairy farm you
grew up bears no resemblance to the
dairy farms of today but nonetheless
mm-hmm how did that kind of did you know
how do you how did that impact like how
you think about dairy products oh my oh
right
it's very profound and so much of what
we're learning about dairy now I brings
pay echoes of the things that I saw
again and this my uncle's dairy farm in
the 50s and and I was a little kid but a
couple of things that still are burned
into my memory I remember the air of
sadness in the dairy barn there are
there cows that they were unhappy
standing there and they often had tears
these female cows had tears go from
their own beautiful eyes and I realized
now today these are all mothers who've
had their babies taken away from them
every one of them that no wonder they're
sad and they and they're just standing
there getting the the babies milk
stripped from them absurd if it's been
taken away
yeah well I'm anthropomorphizing well
the other remember another memory that I
have is the sound of a mother cow locked
up in the stanchion in the barn with her
calf that my uncle just took away in the
veal pen ten yards away and this mother
cow is bellowing hour after hour day
after day the most heart-rending soul
tearing bellows in cries you can imagine
because there
because their infants been taking away
and this goes on for days three four
five days and nights you these haunting
cries are coming and that's the truth of
dairy and you cannot get that milk
flowing without taking that calf away
from the mother it's a cruel cruel
industry from the from forcibly
impregnating the the female cows to
taking their babies away to to killing
the male cows reveal to killing the
mothers after a few years they all wind
up as Hammond read that the dairy barn
is a slaughter industry so the dairy
barns are short stopping off place on
the way to the slaughterhouse for a few
years of calves and and milk now and I
didn't understand that when I was eight
but I sure understand it now and the
memories of those the tears running down
the moms G and the and their cries out
against against their babies taking away
still haunt me to this day it's a cruel
cruel industry so you go vegan in like
1981 cry and and from what I understand
I mean that was it seems like that was
motivated mostly from kind of an ethical
moral compunction initially actually
there it was the conjunction of two very
powerful forces in 1981 I was a resident
in anesthesiology in Vancouver and and
I'm on the cardiovascular service and
day after day I'm putting people to
sleep and I'm watching surgeons open up
their chests and open up the arteries in
their heart and from their coronary
arteries they're pulling this yellow
greasy gut called atherosclerosis out of
their arteries and and I knew what that
stuff was there was already studies and
in journals and talking about what this
stuff is and I realized that I should
pay attention my dad is already showing
signs of clogged arteries to do it would
eventually kill him and and I'm as I'm
watching the the surgeon one day pull a
particularly rubbery slippery piece of
material out of an artery I thought to
myself man that stuff looks like chicken
fat him little voice up my shoulders
said it's a good reason why it looks
like to advance after it is chicken fat
and kalfa
and Pig Fed and the Fed of the animals
this man was eating so from the
operating room I'm getting this message
cook that if I don't change my diet now
that's gonna be me on that table with
that striker saw going up my sternum and
I really don't want they have to happen
I saw those folks and they wake up
they're very uncomfortable so I from the
medical side I was getting the very
strong message but then as you mentioned
you know when I would say fourth-year
med student at University of Illinois in
Chicago I'd spend my Saturday nights in
the trauma unit a big battle Cook County
Hospital
and and all night I would see the worst
that humans inflicted on each other the
physical violence of sexual as you know
psychological violence I would be
shaking by Sunday morning when I walked
out of there and I vowed if I couldn't
rid the world of violence to at least
get out of my own life to become a man
of non-violence and I made a serious
study of it and and I got the books on
from the Indian Saints and maganda about
leading a life of I himself non-violence
and so I really started trying to
institute these my life and so I'm up in
Vancouver and on the cardiovascular
service and one night I'm out for dinner
with a friend of mine and I'm
pontificating about living a life of
non-violence well I'm polishing off a
porterhouse steak at the local Cajun
cleaver yeah yeah job it was great
compassion so that's all very nice
Michael but if you want to get the
fireman side of your life you might want
to start with that piece of meat on your
plate because in satisfying your desire
for the taste of flesh in your mouth you
are paying for the death of the animal
and for the next one in line that's a
slaughterhouse well Susie said that I
might had all the rationales you'll bill
well that's what they raised them for
and the animals dead already you know
but before the words could come out of
my lips the that little voice said you
know he's right yeah he's right yeah
when I went out to pay for the meal I
felt complicit in a crime that
remembered the cows on the farm and had
been no wonder she was crying you know
because they're all gonna wind up I
remember vividly the Bulls being shot in
the head and when a dairy cow stopped
giving milk eat my uncle would call the
far the the slaughterhouse guy and he
would come with his truck and load her
up
I knew the reality of it in a year I was
paying for that system to work and so
between what I was seeing in the
operating room and what I knew in my
heart from that night and the steak
houses that was the end that was it the
line in the sand and so I adopted a
plant-based diet lots of lentil stews
and being chilies and my body loved it
boy within 12 weeks the 20 pound spare
tire a fat melted off my waist my blood
pressure went to normal my cholesterol
went to normal I felt great waking up in
a nice lean body every day and I said
something do this and at that point I
realized I didn't want to be an
anesthesiologist and spend my time
putting people to sleep I'd rather go
back to general practice and help him
wake wake up so I did when that happened
and you had that kind of you know
epiphany with respect to you know how it
impacted your health positively
positively did you then turn to the
medical literature to find support for
the I mean what what was the kind of
state of the Canon of literature at that
time there was not much of it to say the
least
dr. Frey Ellis a physician in England
had published studies of a fellow with
bad angina that was destined for the
operating table went on a vegan diet and
within six months he's hiking up the
mountains in the Lake District in
England and and Frank Sachs knows had
published studies showing the
vegetarians of lower blood pressure they
had lower cholesterol there were already
little flickers and within a year or two
dr. Dean Ornish was published his for
his initial studies and as soon as I saw
his studies I said yep that's right
that's exactly what should happen and so
I was getting in just on the early bread
crumb a stage of have read the
and what did your fellow general
practitioner you know practitioners in
your community think of all this
oh my didn't have a lot of support lost
the thread in indeed yeah yes but my
patients were getting healthy their
support someone in the area to give
plant-based cooking lessons I would send
them to my friends they would give them
the cooking lessons and the same thing
started happening with them and and and
it really pushed my medical management
to a plantain to the wall in that I had
a patient with high blood pressure and I
had among two medications and I get a
call from them so died every time I
stand on I'm getting so lightheaded I
was gonna pass out am i actually
thumping away there and then he says
well my wife took my blood pressure and
it was 70 over 40
and so I urged as though that I said
those those fateful words that I was
urged never to say stop your blood
pressure medication man you got that's
low blood pressure you guessed out their
freakin pills well soon as I said those
words I thought there'd be a puff of
smoke and the ghosts of my internal
medicine professor would lifetime
medication nobody gets all these man not
only can you get him off her medication
you've got to get them off they'll stand
up and pass out on you and so and so Wow
high blood pressure is reversible and
you can this is not lifetime medication
you can get may get these patients off
the off their medications
well once that happened that broke the
old model and now the door was open and
well it wasn't long before one of my
diabetic patients call me and there was
on 20 units of insulin and on metformin
type 2 and type 2 and the blood pressure
with a blood sugar of 30 today I have a
pounding headache the eyes will cut your
insulin in half he calls me two mornings
later it's still running low blood sugar
so I said those faithful words stop your
insolent and you don't need insulin
anymore
so you're expected the right practice
exactly but got him off his medication
he's these now lean healthy guy doesn't
have diabetes and so these two patients
once I have this experience there's no
turning back there's no there's no
denying what I just saw these these
people are getting healthier right in
front of my eyes
and they're so grateful they're so happy
to be off their pills that people don't
want to be sick people yeah my other dog
friends will say paper people won't
change their diet they will change
they're tired of being fat and sick yeah
that was the thing I was gonna ask I
think we're you know on this subject of
patient care there is this sense a that
you know people are not going to change
their lifestyle habits so just give them
the pill that's kind of the conventional
approach here and second to that we're
now kind of in an interesting you know
different type of culture and social
climate where it's not exactly
encouraged to confront people with the
fact that they're overweight or obese or
you know it's like fat shaming or what
out like you know don't stay you can't
tell them the truth about that or like
you know you're beautiful and perfect
exactly the way that you are and the the
combination of those two things I think
you know makes it more difficult to do
exactly what you just explained yes and
I run into that but I don't let it stop
me and in fact in my slide presentation
I've got a picture a plastic model of an
OB see abdomen and and I've been along
with some obese people saying last way I
am and accept me how I am
and fair enough and psychotic but
compassion for these people and there's
all sorts of reasons why they're
carrying this extra weight for the way
they were raised and abuse and their
view of food etc there's no aspersions
on the person but from us but I say from
a completely physical point of view
we're talking physiology here here's
what's going on inside that anthem and I
got a bear we slice the in bento BC
Everman in half
and there are two kinds of fattening up
one is right under the skin the
subcutaneous fat is metabolically active
it produces estrogen it's the largest in
secretion tissue in the body and if and
you do not want it to be obese with 30
pounds of estrogen secreting tissue
pumping out these powerful hormones
plastered on your abdomen if you're a
woman that's a great way to get breast
lumps and and fibroids and bleeding and
and possibly increased risk of breast
cancer estrogens make the prostate gland
unstable it's a greater guy is a great
way to wind up with man boobs and
prostate cancer you don't want the
subcutaneous of fat pumping out all
these estrogens and inside the abdomen
the intra-abdominal fat that wraps
around the intestines that's a different
metabolic cat and that puts out these
molecules called inflammatory cytokines
there that fan inflammatory reactions
throughout the body and they not only
make inflammation worse and joints and
arteries but they also interfere with
the action of insulin and then they make
type 2 diabetes worse and now people can
get all defense if they want but again
your body doesn't care the obesity is
not a state of health it's a state of
inflammation and estrogen access and
this lead this leads to shorten lives
so I'm delicately trying to put that
across but to the doc city you guys got
to know this this is really the reality
of this so the subcutaneous fat is
producing all of this estrogen but but
people are afraid to eat soy it's so sad
and it's a real casualty of this modern
internet Asia news so I got
phytoestrogens gonna give you man boobs
and turn your Sun gate only tofu uh-oh
I've heard all that stuff and it's sad
not only because it's not true but it as
you probably aware the phytoestrogens in
soy are actually protective they
actually block the receptor sites that
the cancer-causing estrogens we are
trying to occupy in the countries where
they the most soy they have the lowest
rate of breast cancer and the women who
with breast cancer who eat soy do better
their cancers grow more slowly so it's
it's one of these unfortunate media
inversions of the truth well it's so
strange how certain foods get conflated
with gender identity and perhaps diet
protocols as well like oh if you're
vegan you're a soy boy you know you're
gonna do whatever you know whatever gets
associated with that culturally and it's
it's so strange oh it is you're eating
meat and you're barbecuing even if
you're just buying it in cellophane
wrappers and
at the supermarket that's um somehow
makes you more of a man
germinal sense and that's why I was so
glad to see the film the game changers
come out so that hopefully will blow
that stereotype out of the water that
certainly made an impact oh it certainly
has curious to see what you would cut a
few big you've got I was just I was with
Louisa Hoya the other day the director
of the film working on some PSAs but you
know dot C bow she yeah I know that some
commercials great cyclist and I'm I'm
not part of the game changers and I've
never met Louie before but it was a
pleasure to meet him and him and and
just to you know congratulate him on the
impact of that movie I mean it's really
you know it's made it's made a gigantic
impacts undeniable absolutely and
hopefully it'll start dismantling that
stereotype that vegetarians are but it
goes back to the siloing and the
confirmation bias and all that kind of
stuff if it was amazing to kind of watch
you know again from a forensic point of
view all the all the rebuttals and the
deconstruction pieces and that came out
in the wake of that you know trying to
hold their ground and you know combat
the the the science and the perspective
of that movie you know because people
want to believe what they want to
believe and and we are in a very strange
time in which it doesn't matter how much
science in fact you put in front of
somebody they're gonna dig in whatever
their their perspective is and and
listen you know the vegan plant-based
community isn't immune from that as well
I see it going on on both sides sure and
you know it's concerning about the
health of our culture in general whether
it's happening in the health
conversation or in the
conversation and all the social problems
that were you know facing right now I
think it's a real it's a real problem
and I'm not sure how we're gonna solve
that when the way that technology is
headed really I agree you know you have
to have faith in the truth and then you
know they say you can't keep a hatpin in
a cloth bag for very long now the point
comes out and the truth is were
plant-eating creatures and when you look
at the environmental cost of creating a
flesh based diet it's destroying this
planet yeah I mean that's the other big
thing that's kind of occurred in the in
the decades since you began this now
there's a whole environmental
conversation around the impact of diet
on the health of our planet that didn't
exist when you began this and I think it
just is another you know everybody you
know has different things that motivate
them or they concern them and now it's
just another on-ramp into why this is a
good idea oh absolutely and to the folks
who are advocating you know Paleo diet
or acute diets you know that you know if
they're I said wait a minute
if you everybody already beaten paleo
really are you truly advocating a flesh
based meal three times a day for eight
billion people talking about we just
don't have the land or the resources to
do it like I'm I'm in support of you
know regenerating our soil and the
impact that regenerative methods of
Agriculture can have and you know I had
you see that movie the biggest little
farm elementary is know you know some
some some local farmers here a
husband-and-wife couple who took a
barren plot of land and turned it into a
thriving ecosystem through these kind of
principles of regeneration and I think
that's great there's something kind of
you know beautiful but also bucolic
about that mmm
and and I think that that is you know
that's a that's a move in the right
direction certainly away from you know
industrial animal agriculture which is
you know basically the the motivating
force behind our Western diet but I
don't think that that model can scale to
feed eight billion people that's the
problem and most people they look at a
regenerative farm and say well I mean
this way but most you know it's like
that's producing very little of the food
that people are eating it's it's really
a pipe dream to think that that's going
to be the solution here that's the point
and with 350 million Americans clamoring
for meat the steak or the burger there
would come off that farm people would be
paying one hundred and twenty dollars
Frank first day and that's just what it
really should cost if we got rid of all
these industrial farms and we just had
these regenerative farms meat would be
incredibly expensive absolutely dispense
with the subsidies and the like exactly
would create greater balance and I think
it would it would make people you know
more mindful but also you know the
economic incentives are out of whack
right no they would be in line with what
it actually is and the impact that these
industries are creating I think we could
write this show oh absolutely
people could only afford to eat this
stuff once a month and that'd be fine
people got through meeting you down to
one at what burger once a month I'd be a
happy doc yeah that would that would
change about the way that it
traditionally always was there's a
delicacy these things were you know
these things were hard to come by exist
it was a garnish or something special it
didn't you know predominate our plate
three times a day
exactly two dollar burgers are you know
an obscenity and every level
economically as well as ecologically and
you know sort of likewise I celebrate
the the innovation that we're seeing
with the plant-based meats with even
possible burgers and the beyond burgers
but I think you know it's becoming more
incumbent upon the consumer to be more
educated about these foods yes they're
vegan but you know they're still coming
with the bun and the ketchup and all the
other I mean you know there's it's like
this is not whole food plant-based this
is a move away from industrialized
animal agriculture and that's great and
I think there are arguments to be made
about the positive health impacts of
these products versus their animal you
know counterparts but let's not be
confused here you're here so you know
how do you think about that because
listen in in 1981 you go to the health
food market slim pickins right about how
turd
you can get you know vegan alternative
to every delicacy that you can imagine
and they all they figured out how to
make these things taste good to sate you
in a certain way and it's very easy and
I found myself doing this I will plead
guilty to this like deluding myself into
thinking like this is an okay choice
maybe it is once in a while I can't make
this you know front and center
exactly I'm a hundred percent in
agreement yeah I'm so grateful to see
these meat like burgers are wonderful
and if it gets Joe Sixpack
meat potato guy off his beef burger on
to that I'm all for it but yeah but
again these are novelty foods you eat
them once a month for twice for their
treat and their transition food for
these folks who need to tiptoe into the
plant-based world and I'm very grateful
for them but where no one's advocating
them as a staple of the diet but by a
longshot we agree one of the things
that's amazing about you know the work
that you've done it's it's one thing to
talk about prevention like let's prevent
people from getting heart disease or
diabetes or high blood pressure and the
like it's another thing to talk about
reversal that's where people start to
get real prickly here yeah but you've
seen you know amazing results and you
know I had we were talking earlier I had
Robby borrow and Cyrus kobata in here
talking about all these case studies of
people that they work with where they
have reversed their type 2 diabetes and
type 1 maybe they've been able to
ameliorate you know the symptom ology of
that and it's really you know really
quite something but this is this is
nothing new for you you've been doing
this for a long time indeed I was on the
medical staff at True North health
center in Santa Rosa California for
eight years and we saw plant-based
nutrition done right and it's most
effective pure from the setting and and
what I saw there just it was stunning
every every medical student every
physician should see these diseases go
away to see lupus go away rheumatoid
arthritis go into remission and high
blood pressure disappear in type 2
diabetes these are reversible diseases
there was somebody had told me that when
I was a medical student and as part of
the lecture that I'm
giving to the students that these are
eminently reversible diseases yeah well
you know if you if you have a gasoline
burning engine you've been putting
diesel fuel in and it is running rough
and black smoke is coming out of it and
then you switch to high Tech's
gasoline mmm my car runs great with our
food so many of these conditions are
just a result of what we're eating well
one of the big interesting protocols at
at true north is the fasting then that
you know that that kind of protocol that
you a nation's under and this is another
area that I think for a long time was
considered you know very fringe
absolutely I know that you know the
staff yourself included I've taken hits
for you know kind of putting people
under this this you know regimen but you
know interestingly now suddenly fasting
is all the vogue right really it's it's
weird how these trends happen like
nobody said any said boo about the
microbiome and then suddenly it's all
about the micro you know like I don't
know how these things percolate up but
right now we're we're in a moment where
people are not only paying attention to
the benefits of fasting and intermittent
fasting you know there's science that's
starting to show up to back it up and
and you know the average person now is I
you know I fast 18 hours a day three
times a month or whatever it is like
this is something that nobody was
talking about even five years ago
whatever's new as old as do we get out
right there the wheel keeps going around
and round but I'm in amazement as you
are to see these things that now
becoming far more widely accepted the
human body and fasting is we had spent a
whole program on that the and let me
take a step back we realize that you
know a million years ago on the African
savannah it was probably pretty common
that four or five days would go by
before you found the next berry bush of
fruit on under the knife Kirkus rotted
in the Sun and these these enforced four
or five day fast were probably the rule
and our body learned how to deal with
that and in fact after 48 hours without
carbohydrates coming in which is our
preferred fuel now the body switches
into burning stored body fat and goes
into this state of ketosis and wonderful
things happen in the early stages
ketosis and the body starts cleaning
itself out it suppresses inflammation it
protects the stem cells so when they
revive after the fast it's a healthier
immune system these wonderful things
happen and we would use the idea
TrueNorth we would put people on water
fast but again this would be so this is
medically supervised and as medical
fasting these are people with runaway
high blood pressure
runaway rheumatoid arthritis lupus these
are our official medical problems in
these people and a fast isn't a
wonderful initial step to to suppress
the symptoms and and start the person on
the road to recovery but as I tell the
patients and the med students who would
rotate through to north
you know the fasting is wonderful it's
powerful it's great but on the screen of
their life is little blip on the screen
what matters is what you read after the
fast it's the food stream day after day
month after month that makes for a
healthy body because if they go on a
water fast for three weeks and they get
those a great improvement but if they go
back to cheeseburger and Pizza land the
Cinderella turns back into a pumpkin
within days of the joints are sore the
blood pressures back the the water
fasting is a step to a whole food
plant-based diet at changi and while
they're water fasting we would give them
cooking lessons and show them videos and
food demonstrations so when they left
they would know what to eat so the
symptoms don't come back so the fasting
is a powerful tool but it's just a tool
in the chest the issue is the food so
patient comes to true north means with
you how do you decide whether or not to
put them on a fast and if so how long to
do it and what is it that you're kind of
monitoring while they're doing it
because at three weeks three week water
fast that's this is not intermittent
fasting this is this is a whole
different thing like how did this begin
as
a procedure or a protocol and you know
what is actually happening with this
person while they're undergoing that I
mean three weeks yes right such an
important question it sounds crazy
it does but first of all it's easier
than you think
by day three hungers gone about one of
the blessings of ketosis it pretty much
turns off hunger and by day three for
though you're not thinking about food as
God's gift of faster so you don't spend
three weeks hungry and in fact all the
energy that would usually be devoted to
digesting your food on a water fast is
freed up and no food to digest and
people feel that energy and they stopped
me in the courtyard archive and felt
this good and here's our gee I haven't
eaten in three weeks but I feel
wonderful it's counterintuitive you
think you're going like you guys need my
alcoholic mind no more food forever
my right and there's a good reason for
this and and the body's using this
energy to heal and to readjust itself
it's it's oh it's a it's a blessed state
but you but you don't do a lot of
physical activity here you don't to drop
your blood sugar it's a special state
it's a good time to get some meditation
done and some contemplation work on your
novel it's a time to be physically quiet
during that time but but as far it's not
three weeks of longer people aren't even
hungry after after a few days the vast
majority of them every once in a while
I'll get some it's my way all the way
through but it is rare most people
they're not hungry
and during this time wonderful things
are happening as far as their the the
underlying disease process that brought
them there in the first place their
diabetes usually getting better they're
blood pressures coming down their
arteries roping up the angina is going
away but there are absolute
contraindications you don't fast type
one diabetes people who are way
underweight that they are not good
candidates for water fasting for
whatever reason people with a lot of
emotional problems probably not a good
idea
children you don't fast there are there
are some
contraindications as far as determining
who does the fast and then as far as
monitoring the fast that's a good word
we wash these people like a hawk the
intern knocks on the door twice a day
how you doing jester vital signs are
true blood pressure pulse and in nausea
and headache getting lightheaded when
you stand up and if we get positive
answers to any of those questions then
we're going to throw up I'm getting
lightheaded that's the end of the fast
it's time for some juice and they get
them on to some some light foods so
we're so if most every healthy person
can you can do a three-day fast at home
five at the most after that you better
be in a place where people know what
they're looking at if you get
lightheaded or nauseated or whatever so
I'm sort of monitoring by an experienced
person is is a really key to doing these
long fasts safely but at home I have
people just on a weekend I've got
patients who just water do water from
Friday to Monday absolutely reasonable
thing to do I think I think good things
happen their body I've got people who
don't eat till noon I think that that
extra six hours in the morning of no
food does good things for them that's
intermittent fasting so there people can
put their toe in the water and get the
benefits without doing these long
medically supervised fast yeah it seems
like science is still very much emerging
in this area I mean you have Valter
Longo who's kind of you know at the
forefront of this you're studying this
and he's come up with his fasting
mimicking diet which allows you to eat
but still produces that same
physiological effect you have such and
Panda they all have to give a little bit
of different opinions on this I had
David Sinclair in here the other day
really was talking at length about you
know what's happening and it went when
you fast how that's impacting longevity
and anti-aging like I think it's a very
cool interesting field mm-hm and perhaps
much more you know needs to be studied
here and I'm wondering whether there's
any wisdom and like why do the
three-week fast when you could do
perhaps the fasting mimicking diet and
you know is there a reason why
you you've you know this Institute where
you used to work kind of settled on this
as being in that way of dealing with us
and I and you know as an important
caveat you're dealing with people are
very ill they're coming to you right
exactly and as you already mentioned the
these the folks are the kind of self
selective they have they've come there
that are willing they're willing yeah
they're ready they're ready to go it is
and it's also you know the the big
league heavy artillery of of nutritional
therapy a full on water fast is very
effective and if I've got a guy we've
had a fellow a blood pressure of 220
over 130 and he goes on four medications
and just nothing was bring him down and
took about twenty seven days on water
fast but fine that that pressure came
down and so those are the kind of folks
that that kind of fasting works the best
for I would imagine also psychologically
it's got to be incredibly empowering or
bringing somebody in who's you know kind
of feeble bodied at the moment and
you're putting in front of them
something that is seemingly impossible
to do and then they do it
it's got to make them you know in
addition to whatever you know spikes and
vitality and you know reduction in their
you know disease markers are just
knowing like how did something
incredibly hard
I would imagine makes them more
motivated and excited about making the
changes that follow and and kind of
taking an insurance policy on and making
sure that they stick oh is huge
that's so perceptive of you rich yeah I
tell them it's like you know the
outward-bound courses where they did yes
you can and they strap you up and they
you're on the rope there and you're
going across and you look down and you
see your own deaths out there you keep
on going and they make it across
you're now someone who did their you
can't say I can't do that you just saw
yourself do that and push yourself past
your limits well a blue on Waterfest
doesn't say I can't do that you just did
it and you'll never be upset about
missing lunch again you know
just went three weeks without food now
and you're right it's tremendously
empowering and it's a real investment
that people want to stick with what are
some of the craziest turnarounds that
you've seen oh oh my we have two
patients with lymphomas come in Rebecca
as an older woman had a had a mass the
size of a grapefruit in her abdomen she
did a prolonged water and juice cleanse
and that just melted right away
lymphoma disappeared this was validated
at University California San Francisco
they biopsied it completely disappeared
completely disappeared Wow without
traditional chemo and absolutely and and
then Yvonne was another one she came in
she also had lymphoma she had lymph
nodes the size of hens eggs and her
groin and her armpit then she did a 26
day fast tumor just melted right away
and she's been cancer free now lymphomas
are special kind of cancers they're
watery and they respond well to -
fasting - the biochemical changes so not
all cancers are created equal I can't
say it's the definitive cure for cancers
but to see that happen and it was just
stunning to me another one of these
things that were told now that never
happens well I just saw it happened
twice so those are two of the most
dramatic and and you know dr. McDougall
has got a big waste basket of pills that
people you know that's right throw in
there and and that's so gratifying
people come in with these bags full of
pills and they leave normal healthy
people and as to walk out the door you
go
yes that's what medicine should be we've
seen the growth of lifestyle medicine
practitioners this is another you know
trend in the right direction it would be
great if there were more people doing
this we're in a healthcare system that
makes it I think kind of too difficult
for a lot of practitioners physicians to
make that choice and back to that issue
of of you know empowering people to make
these lifestyle changes so much of it
it's the follow-up like how connected
are these people to the practitioners
you were talking about the doctors you
know that doctors not going to be around
to see that person when this happens but
to create that relationship where
there's accountability and there's
check-ins and their supports and all of
that I think it's critical in terms of
you know making sure that these things
stick long-term and you know if you're
you know had some of these doctors uh
Robert Oz felt or Michelle McMann and
like there are Michelle Micmac any other
doctors that are doing this very
effectively so I'm interested in your
and obviously true north being an
incredible example of this but you know
how can we you know create better
incentives for physicians to craft
practices like this and create those
those you know communities to promote
this in light of a system that is giving
these doctors 15 minutes prescribed get
them out the door or turn and burn you
know it's the way that it's all set up
right now it just seems wrong headed oh
it's absolutely wrong headed and it's
and it's days are numbered I think that
we're it's inevitable that the current
edifice is just paying doctors to do
things to patient to do bypass grafts to
do colonoscopies etc after the disease
is already started to do these band-aid
procedures very expensive band-aid
procedures and you do to a quarter
million dollar operation and the patient
limps out of the hospital to go eat more
cheeseburgers and beaches and clog up
their graphs so they can come back in
and have another one that's bankrupt
medicine and and it's totally not
sustainable I ran into a and Merrick a
lifestyle medicine meeting nice looking
lean fellow - Kim Beckman thought he was
a doctor he said note I'm not a
physician I'm a plant based insurance
actuary well I said oh oh yeah I said a
bunch of us realize that the vegans
require a lot less medical care and he
said the and the insurance companies
need to take advantage of this
the entire suit model has to have to
collapse down in this way mm-hmm he says
there is value for every CEO that
doesn't go down with a heart attack
there's value to the community for every
young breadwinner who doesn't develop a
colon cancer there's value to the
community and we can quantitate that we
know that someone a diabetic person with
a hemoglobin a1c of 9 which is out of
controlled IV we are going to pay
$15,000 a year for for his medical care
if you can get his his hemoglobin a1c
down to 8 that lowers our cost down to
12,500 we can quantitate every one point
improvement we can tell you how much
money we're going to save off that you
can quantitate a lot of these diseases
says man that gives us a way to do value
assessment for the patient he says the
numbers go like this every time we pay
for a coronary bypass by the time we pay
the surgeon anesthesia recovery room the
rehab etcetera clusters quarter million
dollars than ten fifty thousand for
every and if in a ten-year period we
expect to Korea to pay for ten of those
with a hundred executives here and none
of them have their MI and none of them
and why I'm needing the procedure we're
sitting on that money we'll be happy to
pay the doctor 20,000 will pay the
patient 20,000 will pay the clinic
20,000 we're still sitting on almost
$200,000 profit here there's money in
the system we've just got a rejigger the
way the beams are flowing the bean
counters have to start paying the
doctors for keeping people healthy and
and the patients as well it can be done
and there would free up so much money
all these scans not done procedures not
done we could send kids to college or
you put internet in everybody's houses
we could fix the roads there's such
wealth there we just need to restructure
now we're seeing the way medicines
practice I think that has to go
hand-in-hand
education as well and perhaps and over
all of our litigious society I mean so
many of these tests and scans are driven
by a fear of getting sued well I got
these and they could have given me this
and they didn't yeah yes but I predict
we're gonna see a 180 on that I think
just a matter of time before an angry
Widow walks into the office of a
cardiologist or a cardiothoracic surgeon
says my husband died on that operating
table last month during a four vessel
coronary artery bypass and nobody told
us he could have melted those plaques
away from the inside with a plant-based
diet why didn't somebody tell us this
why was this information withheld from
us when did you people know this how
long has this been in the medical
literature 25 years and she will lodge a
wrongful death suit and I think she
should win that suit because this was a
wrongful death that someone when she
sign you in the when the patient signed
the insert informed consent form it
should say and I've been instructed that
this this these plaques could be melted
away with a with a whole food
plant-based diet someone should have
told him that and and there's gonna be a
couple of lawsuits and that hopefully
will move us in direction we need you
that would be a very interesting test
case oh it sure would it sure would
they'll say well it's not standard of
care well darn well it should be and
we've got to get that dietary counseling
as part of standard of care if you could
craft the perfect health care system
what would that look like compared to
what we have right now well I think the
ancient Chinese had added five hundred
years ago you pay the doctor as long as
you're healthy or keep me healthy as
soon as you get sick the doctor starts
getting better and motivates the doctor
to keep you healthy what are you reading
you know and he's very interested in how
you living your life because his income
stops if you get sick yeah and some
variation on that right the there's so
many ways we could do this the federal
government could help when it comes tax
time and before you fill out your taxes
you go down to the local pharmacy where
the nurse and the urgent care booth is
there and she takes your blood pressure
put you on the scale and and Jen takes a
urine specimen and six your finger for
cholesterol and if you're no more than
five pounds over your ideal body weight
take five percent off your taxes if your
blood pressure's one 130 over 80 or
below take another five percent off your
taxes if there's no cotinine in your
urine from cigarette smoking take
another five percent off your taxes if
your cholesterol is below one 150 take
another five percent off and and she'll
write it up and give you a little ticket
that you submit with your tax return
whoa government's paying me for staying
healthy yeah there's so many ways we
could do this and we would all be better
off for it yeah
where was it I saw I might have this
wrong but I saw a little video I think
it was in might have been in Russia or
China where you could get a free like
subway token if you're you run on a
treadmill or the idea of like setting up
a gym like reversing the gym membership
thing like the gyms free as long as
you're going the minute you stop going
are you signed for a year if you don't
you pay when you don't go no the tools
are all around us we just click are
thinking a little bit get creative yeah
sure I mean we certainly need to make
changes
we sure do I'm not working so well is
now it's a disease care system and the
disease is winning at this point so
somebody if somebody's listening to this
and they're like I'm on board
conceptually I understand this but what
is this I you know I don't really what
does this mean like I've wake up in the
morning okay so what do I eat and how
does this work like walk me through an
ideal you know day in the life of food
and activity and lifestyle in the world
of Michael clock yeah absolutely okay
well as long as you're eating food that
grew out of the ground and has been
minimally processed you're going to be
okay basically though that they're gonna
have another t-shirt made up eat plants
and get on with it yeah you know at this
point cuz that's what it comes your
brain loves to over complicate this oh
we do we some velvet rope and I need
this secret VIP thing really if but
again
this body's been around for thirty
million years and we are plant eating
creatures so in the morning if you're if
you're not hungry don't eat just drink
water till you get hungry that's a
perfectly legitimate thing to do when
there's reasons why that makes sense is
you've been fasting all night it's okay
to extend that into the morning hours so
if you're not hungry don't eat just
drink water if you are hungry bio may
either have some fruit have a cantaloupe
have a grapefruit etc or something more
substantial some oatmeal and some fruit
with it will have milk or rice milk on
top of that so there's breakfast lunches
and dinners I say put them on the 4s
clothes line here salads soups steamed
veggies and starches and so have a big
sale at least once a day you gotta have
that fresh life fresh green stuff for
now so I have a big salad once a day
twice a day is even better I'm a big fan
of these hearty vegetable soups you can
make up a big pot of soup and a crock
pot or a slow cooker and eat off of it
for three days pour a bunch into
Tupperware freezer containers let them
cool put lids on put in the freezer so
you got a bunch of frozen soup portions
bring them out heat them eat them make
life simple for yourself so I'm a big
fan of these hearty vegetable soups I
could live on soup and salad and steamed
greens with that that's largely but what
we eat you need two favorite colors
should be green yellow green and yellow
I have something dark and green every
day whether it's kale chard broccoli
brussel sprouts etc there's something
yellow carrots squash sweet potatoes
yams you need something for the
carotenes so so salad soup steamed
veggies and you need some calories in
the form of healthy starches so I'm a
big fan of sweet potatoes and potatoes
of all sorts but quinoa millet and all
these lovely whole grains and we make a
bow to the sort of legumes as far as
proteins go yeah I have something
leguminous at least every other day I'll
call scoop a lentil stew of bean burrito
being chili hummus and with something
they have some legumes in it if you do
that I'd have some fruit for dessert man
you're gonna body will know what to do
with that you're gonna have a fine food
stream there but dr. K yes what about
protein all right and there's protein in
everything
if you are eating 2,000 calories enough
to keep your weight up of whole plant
foods that grew out of the garden out of
the ground you're going to be getting 50
60 70 grams of high grade protein it
sits in the rice and the beans and the
greens and fruits and everything's got
protein I've in 45 years of Medicine
I've never written the diagnosis protein
deficiency on the chart it just just
does not happen so but again the whole
foods are really important you got to be
able to identify though that's a
cucumber that's accurate that's that's a
green pepper over there yeah it's when
the hand of man to process it into all
sorts of flakes and process through
that's where you get in trouble whole
grains are very much a part of this as
well what have you learned or what's
your perspective on gluten and gluten
sensitivity right it's an issue but it's
it's this much of an issue it's not that
much of an issue there's probably more
of it than we think it's a fairly rare
phenomenon from a strictly medical point
of view and the classic sense where we
Doc's learned that someone who's gluten
sensitive they eat some bread and they
spend the next 6 hours on the toilet
bloody diarrhea that's fairly rare but
there's probably a little local it's a
continuum there's probably a lot of
folks with a low-grade gluten
sensitivity they may not even be aware
of it and they get this bloating and the
gas and the loose stools if there's any
question just stop all gluten for a
month and if your symptoms clear up then
have three slices of whole wheat bread
one day and see how you feel the next
day do you know it's the cheapest best
lab test going and see if they see if
you're gluten sensitive or not you can
test yourself I wouldn't rely on the
blood test at this point I know that
when I eat like if I eat a you know
we're fine bread or pita crust or things
like that if I overdo it with that like
the next day my eyes are all puffy you
know so it's like well clearly there's
some inflammation happening here I don't
know what's happening in my joints or
the rest of my body but there's this
can't be a good thing something is
happening that's my body so I wish I
could tell you I was perfect about that
I'm definitely not but but I sure do
there must be something to that oh there
is
absolutely and you did the right thing
and you're tuned in enough to know that
when I eat this next morning my body's
not here but so all you need to know
you're probably someone who should eat
gluten very sparingly and you've already
gotten that message and so the
lightening doesn't come out of this guy
and strike you're dead but your body
lets you know one way or the other what
about organic versus non-organic in this
day and age it's becoming more and more
significant whether the for a number of
reasons the you have the less pesticides
and herbicides to eat the better I feel
much better about paying those organic
farmers to take care of the soils and to
take care of the earth so I've got
nothing better to do with my penny stand
then buy organic produce and and then as
we've heard from our friend dr. Jeff
Bush know hopefully the organic produce
will have much less in the way of
glyphosate and roundup etc and blessed
by definition of the genetically
modified organisms so all the way around
I'm a big fan of organic produce and I
don't mind paying the extra nickel for
the broccoli what about that person
who's listening in this who's thinking
this all sounds great but like I got I
work two jobs and I'm you know I'm
barely making ends meet you're talking
about you know making all these food it
just sounds like a lot of work and the
learning curve is really high time
consuming perhaps expensive like how do
you work with somebody who is sort of
cost and time restrictive so important
great please I would urge them go to
websites like Forks Over knives and
click on their transition program click
on their recipes they will walk you
through how to make this happen in your
life there's books virgin vegan and
there there's lots of books to help you
get started the engine to website has
some excellent now programs to
transition when the so go to the
websites and take advantage of their
transition programs and also this idea
well that's all it's an expensive way to
eat and takes a lot of time to work
actually not
rice and beans are cheap you can buy a
20 pound bag of rice for 6 bucks you can
buy 15 pounds of lentils for $8 the
staples are cheap and if you're not
spending your money on meat and ice
cream and cheeses you got pennies to
spend on the organic the organic produce
and you can certainly save yourself a
lot of time as I mentioned by using your
freezer make up these big bad soups make
up on a Saturday morning make up 30
veggie burgers and put them in your
freezer now you got a freezer full of
burgers bring mouth heat them and eat
them
so these batch cooking helps and if
there's a store you can buy bags of
frozen organic vegetables already cut up
so in your soup pot just open a bag of
frozen a throw in the bot and and done
you don't have to spend any time cooking
chopping so there's ways around it these
days people die of their excuses they
die of their excuses and you know I
don't want to see that happen any longer
so at this point choose to being chilly
over the beef chili and well the money's
going one of two places either going
towards the food that's gonna make you
healthy or it's going to the healthcare
corner the grocer the doctor later
I know unfortunately that's it's not
great at motivating people you know
we're not we're not so good at you know
forecasting into the future and making
better decisions now for some reason but
that is the truth and there is something
interesting about like like it's
counterintuitive to me to buy frozen
fruits and vegetables like I want to go
to the farmers market it I want it
really fresh but there is something to
be said for those products that are
frozen immediately after picking their
you know so they're basically they're
locking in those nutrients there's no
you know sort of degrading process that
happens in the you know however many
days it takes between picking and ending
up in your grocery store yeah absolutely
flash frozen vegetables are the busy
person's friend absolutely you're
absolutely right and in the mornings
that will thaw out the night before we
go to bed if we're having oatmeal next
morning we take out the frozen mangoes
and cherries from the freezer let them
thaw overnight and we put them in the
cereal the next morning yeah
what is your what's your exercise
routine look like these days you're you
you're runner yes I used to be a runner
yeah I have back surgery too many hours
of the operating table and so now I'm a
cyclist and so either do I love going on
for these 15 mile bike rides but I've
got a an exercise bike a recumbent bike
in my out on our patio where I can watch
I've got a couple of bird feeders so I'm
a bit of a burger that's no bird as I'm
pedaling I could see that but got the
big lens and very importantly I'll get
on the bike crank up the resistance and
start pedaling but then I grab to twelve
pound hand weights and as I'm pedaling
I'm doing an upper body workout and so I
do 40 minutes of upper body while I'm
pedaling you work up a sweat doing that
and I do that every other morning and
and so that's my cardio strength program
and my wife's a yoga teacher so the
mornings I'm not sweating she's got me
on the map and doing salutations to the
Sun my my grandparents retired to west
palm beach they've since passed away but
you know my youth was marked by going to
west palm beach you know once a year to
visit them in the wintertime I mean that
is a community it's it's much more
cosmopolitan now than it was then but
it's certainly you know a very large
retirement community so we must be
interesting for you to be so vital at
your age and to be surrounded by a lot
of elderly people who are much less so
to put it bluntly it is something you
ought to run out good shake that's so
that equation yeah you don't you can't
but yeah it's it's sad it but it
motivates me to to help people not wind
up in that position you're seeing more
and more plant-based restaurants in the
Miami area as well really remarkable
I've got a I've got a folder on my my
computer things I never thought I would
see and
and every week I'm the two or three goes
in there McDonald's serving plant-based
burgers and this and the California
schools and the hospitals now certainly
plant-based meals and all these amazing
restaurants that are showing up that's
really exciting there's a really hopeful
signs have you been to love Life Cafe
and my only no really yeah our good
friends Diego and Veronica run this
amazing plant-based restaurant it's in
it's in the Wynwood district and Miami
just too far from where you know and
they serve amazing food they're just
they're beautiful people too and
cyclists Oh avid cyclists so I'm gonna
connect you okay please do one of the
questions that I always ask the doctors
that I have on the show is what would be
like your number one agenda like imagine
a parallel universe where suddenly you
found yourself as Surgeon General what
are the changes if you had that kind of
power that with broad strokes you could
really you know change policy move them
on a grand level like what you know how
would you get to work if you roll up
your sleeves like what's what's priority
number one well I would end our cultural
subsidies to the meat and dairy industry
and let the market really dictate what
these things sold for what they cost to
produce and if any subsidies are done I
would give it to the broccoli farmers
but I would make healthy produce really
cheap where that just you couldn't pass
it up
and then I would Institute a number of
incentives that I mentioned now as far
as giving people tax breaks for being
healthy helping with their you know
their daily health practices to reward
them in various ways so it becomes fun I
would start in the schools I would get
physical education back into the schools
I would make exercise and healthy eating
healthy for kids and then bring the kids
out to the gardens and the farms and
show how their food is grown and
reconnect them they're suffering from
nature deficit disorder and
but I would connect especially the young
people with the reality of food
production so it's a basically an
educational process as well as financial
rejiggering of the system so rewards
people for staying healthy and eating
healthy yeah it seems elementary to me
that we should build into elementary
education the principles of nutrition so
that young people at a very early age
you know can crock these principles
that's just fundamental so slimming
decisions about how to live am say where
does food come to it comes into
supermarket goes out trees you need to
know that instead we get we get these
subsidy subsidized you know milk
advertisements in high school gymnasiums
oh my really and we've got to stop lying
to our students to each other yeah
mm-hmm
final thing if if somebody's listening
to this and you know perhaps their
health has gone somewhat awry but they
go to their doctor and their doctor is
basically telling them you know what you
already were counted like the typical
like you got to be on these drugs and
anybody who tells you otherwise it's
insane and there isn't they don't feel
like they you know have a community of
like-minded people who are saying things
some what are what you're saying and
they don't know where to turn is there
you know short of going to true north we
what are some resources you know is
there a directory of plant-based doctors
where people could find somebody who's
kind of speaking your language in their
area like where did you point absolutely
the websites peoples know about it are
two of them one is called plant-based
dr. zorg plant-based dr. zorg and
plant-based Doc's calm between those two
of the odds are you'll find somebody
near you
yeah educate yourself get books by dr.
mcdougal dr. Fuhrman dr. Esselstyn and
and all of them are laying out the basic
truths here but basically in plans and
so if you do those who think as you keep
yourself and find a nearby plant-based
physician you'll get all the all the
good advice you need and I would urge
people go to my
our website I've got a YouTube channel
dr. Klapper
yeah all spelled out do ctor que la pers
9dr
and I've got all sorts of instructional
videos there we're adding more and more
to that so check out my youtube channel
dr. Klapper and I love that you're on
YouTube that's great and and if people
want to help our efforts to get me in
front of medical school audiences I've
got a changed man Western medicine go to
my website dr. Klapper comm all spelled
out yo ctrl a PE are calm and click on
moving medicine forward and you'll see
what we're doing not only how you can
help us we could sure use the support
plane tickets are expensive but also
there's a little box to check if you
know a medical student at a medical
school or someone on the faculty you'd
like us to connect with them please give
us their name and now and we will follow
up and connect with that so that's on my
website collab calm people go to moving
medicine forward they'll see they'll see
the work we're doing yeah and they can
follow you on Instagram you can follow
me on Instagram to do it that's
fantastic I mean I think there there is
no worthy more worthy cause than trying
to you know take all of this experience
that you have to try to create you know
the next generation of doctors because
this is where the rubber meets the road
right if we can if we can create a
situation in which this next crop of
medical practitioners has the tools you
know that are required to treat these
things and nip them in the bud we don't
even need to get into reversing because
we're all about prevention at that point
absolutely were in a much better place
absolutely I tell these Susan before you
order another thousand dollar scan
another 500 dollar set of blood tests
ask your patients what they ate
yesterday and if it's full of burgers
and buffalo wings they ask why they're
sitting in front of you send them to the
plant-based diet ition let her do the
counseling let her show on the movies
let her take of shopping you see him
back in a month and see if they're
healthier and they will be so it's time
for the era of nutritional medicine to
dawn
boom all right I love it you are a gift
to humanity my friend you're a beautiful
guy
your message is super powerful so it's
an honor to help amplify your wisdoms
well you do that beautifully thank you
so much for helping keep alright job
well come back and talk to me again so I
hope you I don't you hopefully we'll
meet on the trail out there absolutely
and just to echo what you said
previously if you are in medical school
or you know medical school faculty like
please reach out okay good my website
let's try to let's try to get him
full-time on the road to do alright
absolutely thanks thank you
peace peace
[Music]